hey guys and welcome back to my channel
so in light of Andrew Tate's arrest I
want to give my opinion on everything
that's been going on I want to start by
saying I've seen a lot of people all
over social media jump into conclusions
particularly on Twitter many people are
laughing saying I Told You So and are
saying that he's guilty I think it's
really important to remember that
innocent until proven guilty we really
don't know anything right now all we
know is what people are saying and what
people are claiming so it's really
important to remember innocent until
proven guilty so as you know from my
previous videos I have actually met
Andrew Tate many times we've met in
London in Romania we've done an
interview in Miami and as I've said
before based off of my experience with
him he's always been very gentlemanly
been very nice been very courteous never
made me feel uncomfortable and so
personally again from my experience
cannot imagine that he would be capable
of rape and human trafficking these are
obviously the charges and it doesn't
seem to be in his nature and the charges
seem to be very much out of character so
obviously he did have a webcam business
and from what I understand that was many
years ago although perhaps there is
something to do with only fans which has
been a little bit more recent but when
you do work in that line of business
you're going to get these levels of
accusations it's no surprise to me it's
as they say play stupid games Win stupid
prizes and that's what happens the
webcam business you know managing women
only fans and things like that isn't
illegal but like I said obviously when
you do work in these kind of areas and
you work with women Angela's walking a
very fine line working in that kind of
industry I want to be crystal clear here
I don't support any kind of sex work I'm
actually very against only fans and very
against prostitution and I'm also very
against a webcam business I think that
it's very degrading to women I think
it's toxic I think it's unhealthy
mentally for women and I think that
women should preserve their value women
lose value by showing their bodies off
like that to the entire world especially
when there's a sexual transaction when
there's money I don't like it I think
it's degrading to women and I'm against
it however just because I think it's
unethical doesn't mean that it's illegal
and somebody should be put in jail for
this what Andrew chooses to do is his
business it's none of my business each
to their own as well as far as I know
all the women consent to this so as long
as it's consensual nothing really here
is illegal I also want to be clear that
I don't think there's anything wrong
with men managing women it is a business
at the end of the day and a lot of the
times in my opinion I think men manage
businesses very well however when you
are managing a business of this nature
where of course it's sexual then again
play stupid games Win stupid prizes
there are going to be consequences
people are going to say things about you
whether they're true or whether they're
false my advice to women is always never
get involved in any of these things
preserve your value don't show your body
off to the world I think it's kind of
disgusting to be honest and I think it's
also very unhealthy mentally also I
think what is very interesting and very
bizarre to me is the timing of all of
this Andrew Tate is officially one of
the most influential men of of or if not
the most influential person of 2022 more
search than Kim Kardashian this man has
an incredible level of influence and
power and his message goes against the
mainstream it goes against the
establishment he's inspiring young
people to wake up take personal
responsibility and not be a slave to the
government not be a slave to the nine to
five not be a slave to the establishment
and if you have people waking up and
leaving the Matrix as he likes to put it
and not being reliant on government well
then that's bad for government because
then the population is awake they're not
as easy to control and not as easy to
brainwash so Andrew is inspiring people
to think for themselves and really just
turn against the establishment so it's
no surprise to me that he's been shut
down we had him canceled first then he
came back clearly he's uncancelable so
how do you cancel someone will you lock
them up look I'm not saying that this is
what happened I'm just saying that it is
interesting to me how do you take
somebody down well accuse him of awful
crimes like rape human trafficking I
don't really think other than pedophilia
there isn't a worse crime so it doesn't
really surprised me that this is
happening as well so this is something
to consider at the same time but overall
I do want to be clear that we don't know
what has happened yet I do believe
innocent until proven guilty of course I
hope Andrew is innocent and I hope no
women were harmed I hope no women were
trafficked I hope nobody was raped for
some reason I feel that I have to say
this because people say that I support
human trafficking and abusers and I
obviously don't as a woman I wouldn't
ever support something like that it's
just I don't think that this person is
capable of that innocent until proven
guilty